you are unconventional meaning there's
so many things that celebrities do and
then you choose to go a different way
one is that you like to tell people
you're older then you really are
nobody does that it's business everybody
goes the other way and you actually add
years
what do you yeah yeah nobody knows first
of all I just want to go on record and
say none of it is intentional but thanks
sweet at a time for life yeah I think
that there's you know I mean it's a show
business people love aging down I felt
like why not just start aging up you
know because that way everyone's always
surprised it you know you're not 60 you
look so great for your age
thanks to a wild life I'm a little bit
pickled so on the outside I'm like a
little like a Shirley Temple or like you
know like Dracula yeah it was great we
think of Dracula Shirley Temple yeah but
on the inside if like my internal organs
are more like like a Mel Brooks maybe
who cleans so maybe more like like a
hunter s Thomson upon first Thompson had
a baby with Mel Brooks is like my liver
and yeah yeah yeah with some Dracula and
Shirley Temple okay do you know me and
that's and that's why I'm like yeah
maybe I'm 6065 know your business 6565
you were great
I'm great for sighs thanks
not many sixty-five-year-old swear like
that
you